while traveling alone I accidentally
became a part of a drug deal and this is
that story this all starts my senior
year of college
my boyfriend had just broken up with me
it was right before Thanksgiving that's
a whole other story in itself and I was
a hashtag heartbroken college girl I
headed home for the holidays for some
serious mom time you know paid dinners
homemade meals I'm gonna just hype you
up post-breakup
hi mom thank you so I'm sitting at home
crying my eyes out and my mom comes up
to me and she's like what if you just
went and saw Sabrina you need something
to take your mind off of this by the way
sabrina is my best friend from childhood
who was studying abroad in London at the
time at first I thought my mom was
joking with my achy-breaky heart but she
was serious I was about to graduate and
she said that this would be my gift for
making it through college and I was
stoked so that night we booked my
tickets I was to leave on Christmas Day
and spend three weeks in London in
Austria
fast-forward to Christmas Day I hop on a
plane and I make sure to document every
move on snapchat so my ex sees that I'm
absolutely crushing life and living the
best life without him I finally land in
London I see my bestie and everything
feels like it's gonna be okay
because best friends can do that we
spend a week exploring London together
and in a very similar move to my mom's
Freda goes what if we just went to
Barcelona for the weekend I forget that
in UK and Europe you can just go all
over the place so easily so we buy cheap
airline tickets like 45 euros each way
probably these sketchiest plane ever
anyway we land in Barcelona we check
into our adorable Airbnb and we get to
touristing now this is where the story
really begins it's around definition we
decide to start getting ready for dinner
donning our club outfits because after
dinner we are going to go to the hippest
Club in Barcelona since dinners in
Europe start when I'm basically getting
ready for bed we don't even get to the
dinner place until like 9:00 now at this
point it's dark outside but it's warm
enough to where we can sit outside on
the patio we order food open a bottle of
wine and I'm just sitting in freakin
Barcelona soaking it all in instead of
being on the couch like a little
cry-baby
as we are eating this man approaches me
I'm thinking to myself wow this
is getting very close to me out of
literally nowhere he whips out a brown
paper bag drops it at my feet and leaves
like sir what are you doing why did you
leave this bag does he think I am I
going to die a million thoughts start
flooding my brain because I'm truly the
most anxious more of a person I know
I've already planned my funeral it's
fine that's not a joke my funeral is
actually planned so here I am staring
down at a bag filled with who knows what
I spend about two minutes hysterically
freaking out when all of a sudden the
man returns and he looks visibly
panicked like yeah hey Sam he grabs the
bag and then runs off into the distance
I honestly blacked out so who knows
where he was going but I imagine it
being very Colton esque he just jumped
dancing in reality I think he probably
just slipped into a back alley and
disappeared my friends and I look at
each other even more confused than
before and that's when the police show
up like really I just wanted to come to
Barcelona see my best friend while maybe
simultaneously rubbing it in my ex's
face yet Here I am the police start
yelling at me where did that man go we
saw you give him something where is the
bag they kept shouting about the bag and
I don't know why they cared so much
about the bail that bag 1,000% had drugs
in it chill very chill at this point my
voice is shaking and I respond I don't
know I'm not from here but he dropped
the bag off came back to get it and then
he ran that way just as fast as they
showed up the police ran away in the
direction that the guy just went once
again I look back at my friend can
someone help me process this what is
happening are we going to the club are
we going to jail are we going to die we
finally begin to compose ourselves when
I'll give you a second to guess what
happens next the drug man returned again
without the bag he starts
at me what did you tell the police they
are looking for me I saw you talking to
them me a totally chill not anxious 21
year old starts screaming back I don't
know who you are I didn't tell them
anything so I absolutely did I
definitely sold that man out I'm so
scared because now I know that the
police are after him it felt confirmed
that he was the bad guy and I was caught
in the middle he's screaming at us for
maybe a minute threatening us everyone
is freaking out then the guy just books
it and runs away again that's it I was
sure of it this dude is probably part of
some drug cartel he's going to return to
his boss and tell him all about this I
mean he said he was watching me they're
gonna put a hit out on me I'm gonna be
dancing at the club and die all because
this guy is clearly bad at his job lost
his drugs with me and now everyone is
gonna die all my friends are clearly
just as upset so we collectively decide
it's just time to go to the club well
drink and loosen up and everything will
be fine we're walking and every face
that passes just feels like they're
staring at me you know what I'm not fine
I'm terrified we get on a train and I
tell my friend you know what actually
there's no way I can go to a crowded
Club it's too scary of a setting with
everything that just happened at this
point I'm in tears and I begged my
friends to take me back to the Airbnb we
get back and I spend the rest of the
evening paranoid that I'm just a sitting
duck waiting to be ended for knowing too
much
eventually I finally get myself off to
sleep the next morning the Sun comes up
I'm alive and my paranoia has somewhat
wait I'm quickly reminded of why I'm
there to spite my ex okay and to see my
best friend's obviously so that night I
put on my cutest outfit
go to that club I danced with not a care
of who's watching drink so much wine and
have the time of my life I'm out all
night and at 6:00 a.m. I drunkenly
stumbled to the airport and get on a
plane back to London and then the rest
of my vacate
no assassins no high-speed chases
no giant bags filled with drugs just a
lot of fun and eventually as you can see
I finally made it back to the United
States safe and sound now in case you're
wondering about what happened to the ex
well we got back together shortly after
the trip and we've been together for
four years
[Music]